hallo mein name ist luca und ich mag
alpakas
deswegen spielen wir heute ein spiel was
lama in your face heißt ja ich weiss
lamas sind keine alpakas aber ich habe
leider kein spiel mit alpakas gefunden
wir klicken einfach mal auf start game
das ist auf jeden fall schon mal richtig
geil design eigentlich okay wir können
jetzt hier auf mode city klicken und
dann sehen wir heute play okay ich hab
es mittlerweile jetzt verstanden das
heißt wir können hier einfach
draufklicken und uns auch schon wieder
sein langer text
ok jetzt haben wir alles gelesen das
spiel besteht bisher nur auslesen okay
ich befinde mich in diesem trampolin und
muss quasi visitors abschießen und von
den leuten kann ich dann auch das geld
einsammeln und von dem geld kann ich mir
andere sachen holen wie beispielsweise
helikopter oder irgendwann schaltet was
habe ich denn jetzt bekommen die musiker
schneller und ich bin ich bin sowieso
ein regenbogen gefährt alter was ist das
bitte für ein spiel
ich muss visitors abschießen und bin ein
lama auf einem trampolin okay ich habe
level 1 abgeschlossen die hydrate betrug
41 wir sind das die vierte bla bla bla
und so weiter und so fort
und jetzt kommen wir schon in zweiter
level und ich meine dass es sogar weiß
ich kann mir sachen kaufen okay dann
gebe ich dir einfach mal ein bisschen
geld für aus- und mehr kann ich nicht
ausgeben das heißt wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal weiter zu level 2 in der
nacht und ich muss jetzt hier sitzt das
abschießen new gott der hat leben alter
was das wird ja immer schwieriger hier
wu hongbo okay jetzt gibt es auch noch
geist alters denkt der ernst von dem
spiel ich weiß gar nicht wie sonst in
einen level 5 oder so sein ich möchte
man ja genau das da oben habe ich mir es
gerade sehr sehr gerne wünschen ich
möchte auch mal ganz gerne eigentlich
wie wird gesagt man kann sich irgendwie
so helikopter holen und sein schiff aber
irgendwie konnte ich das bisher nicht
oder mit helikopter war gemeint dass ab
und zu ein helikopter vorbeikommen und
in sachen bringt wie beispielsweise
dieser zeit bonus oder dieser combo
denkt sie nicht bekommen hat oder sorgt
in kombi 15 und was bringt mir das jetzt
nichts level 2 chevaux schon wieder ein
neuer was macht er diesmal nicht um mein
gott alter freunde es werden schon viel
viel mehr leuten und dieser kleine
[ __ ] da der so doppelt so schnell zu
die anderen weg kommt auch direkt mit
zum blöden luftballon noch ruhig kommen
gar nicht mehr klar johannes
einzusammeln könnte man so ein bisschen
ruhig bleiben vielleicht damit ich mal
kurz meine privatsphäre als lava
genießen kann nein da ist doch nicht
jetzt ordert ist das unter einer [ __ ]
bei mir rein gekommen einer von euch
richtig zu sehen
ich bin das sieht aber eigentlich ganz
froh aus euch das an wunder vollbracht
habe ich dicke dinger also dicke dinger
mit denen ich auf die schießen kann und
ich meine ich meinen
ich glaube ich hab schon schon verpackt
wieder was ist denn los mit diesen
kleinen fächern könnt ihr nicht einfach
euch andere tiergehege suchen und dahin
gehen
dies und muss ich denn jeder la massana
ok lamas sind schon sehr schöne tiere
aber ich finde eigentlich bisher kriege
ich das ganz gut hin also bisher war es
noch nicht wirklich anspruchsvoll habe
ich die ganze zeit das ganze fraser also
die ganzen münzen und audi immer schon
relativ krass am anfang weil bisher
läuft eigentlich muss wirklich sagen
dieses lama ist ein sehr sehr schönes
und gutes lerne ja als ob ihr da schon
anfangen mit eurem blöden luftballons
fliegen seid ihr denn wahnsinnig das ist
gefährlich für so was von meinen
flugschein einzuplanen und wir haben
wieder nur eine uhr bekommen sie was mir
aufgefallen ist man bekommt nicht nur
immer nur sondern man bekommt quasi
diese uhr aber diese uhrzeit nur an wie
lange das power up noch da ist
wir haben level 4 geschafft das ganze
heißt man bekommt keine uhr als power ab
sondern man bekommt immer was anderes
und die uhrzeit an wie lange man das
auch artig dummkopf ab die ganze zeit
einzeln gedrückt und ich kann einfach
die maustaste gedrückt lassen
das zeigt schon wieder wie klug ich
einfach bin um mein gott wie viele von
euch bastarden kommen denn mittlerweile
hoch was ist das denn
was soll das wieso kommen denn so viele
aber mein leben ist trotzdem immer noch
nicht voll das wundert mich immer so ein
bisschen regalen ukh und es sind wieder
die dicken dinger und jetzt bekomme ich
wahrscheinlich wieder combo des todes
oder oh mein gott 18 combo 21/22 combo
25 acombo alters war ein 28er combo
gerade ganz viel cash um mein gott 2660
cash habe ich damit gerade eingesammelt
wie viele pässe von euch haben denn so
einen scheiß luftballon
was soll das könnt ihr euch nicht
irgendwie mal 'nen jetpack oder ein
flugzeug oder so kaufen diese sturm
luftballons in den fünf geschafft und
wir kommen zu level sektortitel das
letzte level dein aber vorher kaufe ich
mir noch
das kann ich mir dann mittels cash carry
fordert birgit hiller krise
wahrscheinlich level 6 startet und
direkt sind alle mit ihren blöden
luftballons direkt bei mir am käfig oh
mein gott absolute combo incoming wo
schon die 22er kommen und jetzt hier
eine 35er combo alter freunde was geht
selbst 65 73 acombo hatten wir gerade um
ein fucking gott das spiel kann so
scheiße sein die sonst was
ich finde immer geil wenn ich eine
concorde und viele leute damit irgendwie
töten kann oder irgendwie hohe
punktzahlen qingdao mein gott ich weiß
nicht ob ich diese level diese rallye
hier grad überlebe so viele leute hier
gerade ankommen alter das ist doch nicht
wahr ich viele von euch bislang haben
dann auf einmal luftballons und mein
gott ich hab das gerade nur noch für
halb überlegt und ich habe nur noch ein
leben und jetzt kommen hier von der
einen seite schon so richtig viele leute
und ein scheiß taxi auch noch alter wie
soll ich das denn überleben ja
wahrscheinlich kommt ihr dann auch noch
mit eurem suisse luftballons an genau
höchstwahrscheinlich ist es so egal
freuen ich würde sagen dass war es dann
heute mit dem game lama in your face
vans euch gefallen hat will ich meine
bewertung freudig wird mich auch über
ein abonnement auf freuen und wenn ihr
andere coole spiele kennt dann schreib
ihr doch gerne in die kommentare